hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well let's take that
camera what are you guys thinking cause
that's about right the tripods another
10 blocks or so so yeah how much do you
think these desks cost Maris I have no
idea what they pay for these sort of
things would you guess because they're
because they're so uncomfortable yeah I
think it's probably worse than that but
I am sympathetic to the so the devaluing
of them I would I can't see paying much
for one of these sort of things I can't
see anybody buying them for their own
pleasure either what's this worth
that's more even though it's barely used
what you'd pay for an iPhone that's if
you do that's if you're like turning it
in and getting another one or something
how much would you pay like on the open
market
yeah about 600 bucks we have you know
how much do you pay for a cup of coffee
what do you consider a good price yeah
what do you what do you consider a good
price I'd like to pay for a cup of
coffee - yeah and you know if you go
over to the cafe it's a little bit
slightly a little bit more than a walk
but that's not a bad price go to
Starbucks they'll charge you a bit more
right does that bother you you know
maybe you're paying for the ambience and
stuff like that so here's the basic idea
you pay for things all the time and all
of you actually are in the process of
acquiring talents which you are
hopefully going to get paid for using
right somebody's gonna pay you to you
know do whatever it is that you're
you're learning how to do some of you
are going to be teachers or something
you're going to be accountants some of
you are going into business others are
going into all sorts of other fields
somebody should pay you for that right
this is a basic concept that we have how
much do you do things cost well this is
this applies to our character as well
and this applies to the way we make
decisions
Epictetus says we always think about the
price of things so he talks about
figuring out what's appropriate to us
you know there are some things that are
probably more appropriate to me less
appropriate to you because
time-life my age right there's some
things that are appropriate to you that
are not appropriate to me students he's
got a kind of funny example here attacks
about holding a chamber pot for somebody
else now that's literally a pot to piss
in you know when you hear that old
expression people before they have
toilets they have these chamber pots and
they're called chamber pots because
they'd be in the room and you do your
business of them and then they'd empty
them out later on and if you're really
somebody somebody would actually hold it
for you and that's how you can tell he's
really made it in the ancient world or
the medieval world all right I suppose
even the early modern world that's how
they started putting privies and things
like that he says how do you determine
whether you ought to do this sort of
thing so think about any sort of
degrading thing that you've had to do
think about the worst jobs that you get
with a fire and some of the crap stuff
that you've had to put up with now why
did you put up with it why was it was it
worth it to you looking back on it did
you say I should have told that person
to go take a leave I know I if I look
back on some of my jobs that I've worked
there's probably some circumstances all
right if I should have said forget this
and there were a lot of job done
actually did quit you know I remember I
quit one job because they told me that
it dust shelves was a gas station and
you know working second shift in a gas
station you gotta sell stuff to people
and you know take care of the pumps and
all that but then there was a lot of
time for reading and writing letters but
they had a camera and the blocks
actually said okay no more writing
letters no more reading books or
anything like that under spare time what
do you expect us to do is you send us
shells and I said that's it that was the
chamber pot room I guess you guys would
probably had some stuff like that all
right so how do you tell whether you
should come up with her now he says for
one man it's consistent with reason to
hold a chamber pot for another to look
to this only if he does not hold it he
will receive strikes he's going to get
he's gonna get punished and he won't
receive this food but if he does hold
the pot he
won't stop for anything harder
disagreeable another man not only does
the holding of the Champa pod appear
intolerable and tolerable for himself
but also intolerable to allow another to
do this for him
so we have different ideas about you
know what offends our dignity what goes
against who we are you got to ask
yourself this question why are doing
that what are you do getting out of them
what is the trade oh and you know what
are the things that motivate people
right that's one reason why we do things
isn't it yeah pleasure
yeah yeah attention yeah very good a lot
of stupid things just to try to get
attention today some people on the
supposition that any attention is good
attention what is this guy trying he's
trying to avoid
what's really important to you will you
do anything for money or there's some
lines you will cross some things that
you think are more important for you
then everything has its price its
monetary price there's nothing you
wouldn't do for money right yeah what
about the rest of it is there any lines
you wouldn't cross
that's a good question I'm not gonna can
I say obviously calming you know there's
a lot of price all these sorts of things
right I mean some people would say I
would never I would never do it
why would you never do it you know some
people might say hi some people say
what's wrong
and I don't want to be forced into doing
a wrong action how much would you how
much money would you accept for putting
your parents be in harm's way what a
million bucks attempt to ten billion I
may need to be set for life at the ten
million right get yourself some new
parents trading can track I mean these
are the sort of things that people that
actually have to think about that's what
he means by a price so he says if you
ask me whether you should hold a chamber
pot or not and I say to you if the
receiving of food is worth more than the
not receiving and being scourge is a
greater indignity that not being scourge
and you measure your interest by these
things
gold the chamber pot makes perfect sense
for you to do that that's being rational
if those are your principles if that's
how you measure things if you say well
that would not be worthy of me I'm
better than that I am worth more than
that he says well then that's up to you
you are the one who's introducing this
this is an inquiry that I'm for you know
yourself how much you are worth to
yourself and at what price you sell
yourself so this is the fundamental flex
what Christ
sell yourself that's worth considering
maybe there's some things that you
shouldn't do maybe it shouldn't be you
know do anything for money because maybe
there's some things that later on down
line you said that was a bad deal the
money was not worth the indignity that I
had to put up with you know or it could
be you know the attention wasn't worth
the pleasure was avoiding the discomfort
wasn't I should have done something
different if you say that then you're
saying I was worth more the trouble is
once you've actually sold yourself you
may not be worth anything he has some
examples here in the enchiridion this is
some interesting stuff he says when
you're going about any action or bind
yourself with nature the action is if
you're going to bathe now do you guys
know about like the Greeks and the
Romans and some baths and stuff like
that or is this something that didn't
make you thought just like an individual
bathtub yeah the Greeks and Romans you
did have a few houses that actually had
an individual baths inside of them for
the most part you went to the public
baths yeah the public baths were these
gigantic complexes and they actually oh
they were like spots basically cuz
they'd have you know hot hot water and
cold cool water or room-temperature
water and then they have places where
people with massage and olive oil into
you and they put so much olive oil but
they actually had scrapers to scrape the
excess oil on your skin and some of them
then like you know mud baths and things
like that the kind of things that people
go to spas for now instead of thinking
the baths think going to the public pool
how many of you have gone to the public
pool how fun is that it's a great
experience
why not is it as fun as going to a
private
why not people are dirty yeah if you get
in the water you can't be completely
sure about what isn't what else is in
the water right that depends on the
cleanliness of the pool what else
that's one irritation what else is here
you lack privacy of any surface extent
nothing usually no easy to right you
know kids are running all around and
doing things somebody stands and your
son you can't get the chairs that you'd
like you nobody could run down the whole
list he's talking about something like
that he says if you're going to bath
take sure to yourself the sort of things
that typically happen in the bath some
people splash the water you know some
people splash the water just because
they get into careless some people
splash the water around to you because
they're jerks right some push some use
abusive language others steal if you
leave your stuff out right you want a
locker in a public pool because
otherwise people will take your stuff so
he says you will more safely go about
this action if you say to yourself I'm
gonna go down to bathe and keep my own
mind of a state conformable to nature
you have to say to yourself if you're
doing this example it was not only to
bathe that I desired but to keep my mind
in the state conformable to need you to
keep myself calm to keep myself in
control that's the price sometimes it's
paid for things I will not keep if I'm
bothered at things that happen
he talks later on about doing that
servants slaves back right and we don't
have servants for the most part but we
we do have people that do things for us
right where do we pay people let me
paint you know for this right now right
what else do you pay for it here and
your ordinary day yeah go to restaurants
yeah we go to the cafeteria I suppose
it's on your meal plan but you paid for
right what so restaurants classes what
else in the life of the student do
something you're paying for good
haircuts the less frequently the meeting
but you know yeah that's important we
can get irritated about haircuts
anything else you guys ever do well
let's just stick with that so you go to
the restaurant right what do you want
from a restaurant good food that's not
enough though right yeah good service
that's the server can be a jerk
sometimes it happens right you don't
have any control over that do you you
have some control if you act like a jerk
to the server probably like a jerk to
you unless they're having a particularly
good day or a particularly well trained
but you don't actually control that so
you know you go across the street or
down the road what's what's a restaurant
around here you guys recommend anything
none here's the mean in town
any place that you can figure that it's
particularly good service that's struck
you before in the past
well what's up lows low lows then around
here okay
so when you go to Lola's and usually
they have good service now it's a new
person there they come to the table they
knock here your water over what else
they don't have attentive to you and all
that are you gonna love their table or
do you say to yourself well this is the
price of going to restaurants you don't
get everything necessarily that you you
want this is the way the world works are
you going to sell out your peace of mind
for a napkin for a bread rule for some
spilled water you know that's up to you
and the way that you worry yourself
he has another good example here since
is anybody preferred before you end with
entertainment or an accomplished or
being admitted to a consultation these
things are good you ought to be glad
that he's got if they're bad don't be
grieved you don't have them and remember
that you can that without using the same
means acquire things not in your control
expect to be thought worthy of an equal
share for how can he who does not
frequent the door of any great man who
does not attend them does not praise
them have an equal share with one who
does if you want people to treat you in
a certain way you you know and that
requires sucking up to them well you
probably have to suck up to them that's
the price that you have to pay for it
and that's really what you want then you
need to do that if you want that that
you know that good and it doesn't you
know it's silly to complain that you're
not getting the same thing as somebody
else who did these you know the brown
nosing as we say right because they're
the ones who did it if you didn't sell
yourself out for that you actually did
the right thing for a penis if you did
yeah you shouldn't be jealous of those
people that's a sign of not getting
things right according to two stomachs
so about prices